the ant king marowam easily the
strongest character to have ever been
featured in hunter hunter at face value
he is nigh on perfect and an impossible
task to overcome however even with those
overwhelming odds defeating meruem is
much more achievable than you might
think
hello and welcome to the new world
review source for everything anime and
manga and today we are back with some
glorious hunter hunter in order to
examine one of the more enduring
questions left lingering by togashi's
media beast which is
is there anyone in hunter hunter who can
actually defeat marijuana not exactly an
original video topic but also one that
i've never really seen a good answer to
whenever this question gets asked it is
immediately derailed by almost 100
pure speculation and head canon example
there is a video out there by nen mack
called five people who can kill marowan
and not a single one of those five
choices are grounded in
any kind of evidence and i don't mean to
call ned mack out or anything i have
nothing against the guy it's just that
out of all of the uh the characters who
can defeat marowan videos his happens to
be by far the most viewed so in this
video not only am i going to provide you
with five characters who can defeat or
even kill marijuana we're also going to
go over the choices in that video and
discuss
why they might not have been the best
before we begin here's a little warning
though
yes there are five characters who can
beat meruem but these are not going to
be the sexy answers you might be
expecting for example i'm not going to
throw jing freaks into the mix and go
nah yes
jing is like the strongest of the nen
dudes and he will duel marouane in this
epic 1v1
or shatter the very world because that's
just
not how hunter hunter works you know how
hunthunter does work
painfully constructed nen technicalities
that
is the lifeblood of this series there is
no character in hunter hunter who is
outright immune to everything
not even the ant king nor am i saying
that the characters who could defeat him
are guaranteed to do so i'm just saying
that
under the right circumstances however
unlikely those may be
they do have a win condition meanwhile
your win condition would be to hit the
subscribe button for the new world
review thus activating an ability
allowing you to receive regular
injections of hunt hunter content
administered straight into your youtube
feed it's a very handy power that you
will need going forward so i'd highly
recommend not neglecting this gorgeous
gorgeous red button but let's begin with
an obvious one as an example the first
character who can beat
and or kill mirom is obviously alaka
more accurately nanika i suppose but
it's much of a muchness wish granting
though is undisputedly the most powerful
ability within the entire series because
it does hold quite literally infinite
potential especially when wielded by a
certain kilowatt but even without
kilauea all a person needs to do is make
the very simple wish something along the
lines of uh
kill the ant king marowam and that will
be done without question
and with a delightful eye now the cast
that's going to be incurred as a result
of making that wish
is going to be pretty pure insanity and
it may even result in the bulk of
humanity being killed when the next
person fails to fulfill alco's requests
but we're not concerned
with that for this discussion what's
worse though is that there isn't a
single thing that marowan could do about
it this child on the other side of the
world could just take him out in the
blink of an eye and this does also make
quite a bit of sense given that nanika
is also a creature of the dark continent
and its threat level
was even classified as an a whilst the
entire colony of chimera ants including
marijuana were curiously only classified
as a b
so there we go that's the easy character
done switching up into debunk mode now
one of the characters featured in nmx
video and one that always comes up in
online forum discussion as well is
jing freaks there is an absolutely
stunning assumption made by fans that
jing in a process that i can only
describe as
somehow could take on and even defeat
meruem this is because he is quite
possibly one of the greatest human men
geniuses in existence and he has even
been referred to as one of the five best
men users in the world specifically by
neterror specifically by netaro before
meeting meruem and the rest of the ants
i suppose but the thing is that
jing is a question mark character just
knowing what we do about him is not
enough to say that he could conclusively
beat or kill meruem
firstly because the pinnacle of human
standards of nenus were barely enough to
you know scratch meruem and secondly
because we
don't know jing's abilities we do know
that he's talented enough to replicate
very basic abilities of others but he
would need to have something pretty
special to stack up against meruem which
he may have i'm not saying it's
completely impossible but with all of
the available evidence jin currently
does not possess a win condition for
this match-up
and any further discussion is raw
speculation at best although i will say
if we did need to place a blind bet on
one of these question mark characters
he would probably be the best one now
for the next character who can actually
kill mirom it is manga time now because
here we have second prince camilla of
the kakin empire and she has a very
nasty ability that i've covered a fair
bit on this channel because it always
seems to pop up and be relevant but it's
called
cat's name and it is a counteractive
hatsu that only activates in the event
that camilla is killed but upon meeting
that morbid requirement
a big old nen kitty appears and
transfers the life energy of the killer
back into camilla which is a fun rhyme
but thus resulting in the death of said
killer and the life of said camilla so
it's slightly more complicated because
it does require merowim to actually kill
camilla which is
it's more or less likely depending on
where we find marouane in his lifespan
early marijuana would probably murder
her without question
whereas post rose meruem seems much more
unlikely to do so so it's a very tough
question but the point is more that it
is definitely possible it's another
instant win condition against the most
powerful character to have ever existed
in the series all based on a fun
nen technicality one that is
extraordinarily difficult to anticipate
as well this is one of those situations
where the inexperience of the ants would
pretty much instantly do most of them
like the squadron leaders and the royal
guard they would never see this coming
in a million years marowam i suppose is
much more perceptive than they are but
that depends entirely on which of the 40
days of his life that we catch him and
even then it is still undeniably
possible for camilla to pull this off to
hop back aboard the debunk train now
choo choo another character that gets
brought up painfully often in these
discussions is maha zoldik who may or
may not
also be zig-zol dick it's very confusing
i've made a whole video about it which
you should absolutely check out here but
maha also gets brought up a fair bit
because he is or at least he was
implied to be on a combative level on
par or even greater than that of isaac
netaro netero is actually stated by
xenozoldic to have been the only person
to face off against maha and live to
tilt the tail so we are looking at some
pretty serious power behind this pretty
shriveled prune but this is even worse
than the jing situation because in
maha's case we don't have a single shred
of evidence regarding his nun abilities
and you know at least
jing well he's done something that we
can latch on to but in addition to that
maha is clearly no longer in his prime
either and the only way he could stack
up against meruem is through a highly
favorable ability like cat's name or
wish granting which we simply cannot
just go ahead and assume he has
sometimes the greatest and most powerful
figures in the series don't have the
right utility at their disposal
and in fact the more powerful the
character is the less likely these weird
technical advantages are to pop up
because the stunningly powerful aura
users
they just don't generally need them
netero being a prime example of that so
maha
is he exists i guess but you cannot in
good faith say much more about him than
that least of all that he could
beat or kill mirom as for someone who
could let's head back into manga town
and say hi to a character who very few
people probably realize even exists and
it is rehan he has a very dangerous
ability called predator which manifests
into another instant win condition by
implanting the quote predator inside the
body of a target which then grows and
theoretically evolves into the natural
predator
of whatever the target is however the
problem being that this evolution is
assisted by how much rehan is able to
learn about the target in question so
i'll say this right here and now
in a straight up combat scenario rehan
has a zero percent chance of unleashing
the predator and having enough time and
opportunity for it to learn to grow to
the point of countering marijuana it
would need to be a much more long-term
long-distance project but what does go
in predator's favor is that it's
actually incredibly weak against users
who have multiple net abilities mostly
because it just takes longer to learn
what they are and for example that's why
rehan decided it was a very bad matchup
against karapika who has roughly a
billion
different hatsu whereas meruem on the
other hand for most of the series did
not possess
a single nen ability and he only ever
developed one original hatsu so that
does make rihann's job incredibly
straightforward in a way because to be
perfectly frank there isn't much to
learn about meruem other than he's a big
strong dudebra with only basic nen
functionality so fulfilling the
conditions of predator
are not entirely inconceivable and look
it's a long shot it's a massive
long shot actually and 999 times out of
a thousand i don't think that this is
going to work but it is definitely
possible which weirdly enough is more
than i can solidly say for jing
maha or our third character to debunk
being pariston hill once again
paristan is a complete question mark
conceivably he could have a sneaky
ability that would catch meruem off
guard because paristan is indeed a
sneaky rat man however we know even less
about paristan than we do of jing we've
not even seen paris and invoke nine in
the series beyond producing a simple
rent to intimidate cheatle and
sort of menacingly agree jing and really
if you were going to argue for barristan
then i don't see why you wouldn't throw
in like half of the other zodiacs as
well because you'd be making the exact
same argument either way like why are we
choosing paris and over say bottom by
who we also
know nothing about except that he's
apparently good enough at something to
have risen to this rank and i suppose
the most unfortunate thing with paristan
is that his greatest asset shown thus
far is his genius level intellect
something that marowan can match and
even surpass without issue so there's
not
a ton to grab onto with barristan in
this discussion it's just a whole lot of
pure speculation and while we're here
let's also do gone now nanmak didn't use
gon or adolcon in his video but plenty
of others do and it's all due to a
misconception in the anime where pito
states that god's power is now equal to
that of the king
and this is one of those very
controversial choices that the anime
made because it doesn't reflect what
pito
actually stated in the manga which is
that his fangs may
sink into the king thus highlighting
gone as a potential danger but certainly
not an equal but the thing is
even if adult gone was equal in power he
would still not be able to defeat
marowan and if you'd like a more
detailed explanation as to why i have a
whole video on this topic ready for you
right about here now as for the fourth
character who could
kill mirom here's where we're going to
get quite annoyingly technical because
let's all say hello
to nov and nov is here because unlike
the question mark characters we do know
for a fact that he has a power capable
of beating meruem even if his mental
state would never give him the courage
to you know
actually use it nov's hide and seek as
well as scream are two of the most
underrated nun abilities in the series
and in fact scream can one shot anyone
or anything that nov successfully makes
contact with because the whole aspect of
teleportation into a pocket dimension
bypasses any and all defenses be it none
based or simply a tough anti-exterior
the big issue is would nov ever be able
to land scream on meruem
and that is highly unlikely it would
have to be a very convoluted scenario
like nov teaming up with melee iran and
using scream in tandem with god's
accomplice
something along those lines could work
but to be completely honest the scenario
i find much more likely to play out is
not
just walking up to merrowam and saying
hey follow me
then opening up a portal with hide and
seek fearless meruem then wanders into
the pocket dimension where nov seals him
in a specific room once again taking
advantage of merowem's inexperience and
confidence bordering on arrogance which
definitely did happen when he was happy
to walk into netro's trap so there's a
pretty strong precedent for meruem just
going along with what his opponents want
to do
and while both of these scenarios are
still an ion impossible to achieve
primarily i'd say due to knoll's mental
state more so than anything marowam does
they
are still genuine possibilities to kill
trap or defeat marowan meanwhile next on
the debunk list is the currently manga
exclusive character beyond netro as the
name implies he is the son of isaac
nataro and as the name also implies he
may very well be more powerful than his
father other than that we know sweet fa
about beyond he's a clever boy i suppose
having orchestrated this whole dark
continent arc but there's no way that
anyone could honestly state that beyond
could pull this off without a whole ton
of caveats such as in my opinion beyond
is probably
maybe strong and smart enough to have
crafted an ability to deal with a god
like ant
maybe putting this character in this
situation and claiming that you have an
outcome
just goes beyond any reasonable thought
and before i reveal the final character
who could beat marouane let's also
tackle crowler he's always a tricky one
because the argument in his favor is
that generally with enough planning time
crollow could pull off anything and
maybe he can but i still think it's a
pretty extreme stretch to throw him in
against meruem even with planning time
and let's be clear
that time is not infinite marijuana was
only alive for 40 days so let's say
that's krollo's maximum in that time he
needs to understand meruem his
capabilities and prepare a full counter
and to put that into some perspective
crollo was running around and planning
for almost an
entire year just to be able to counter
hisoka and bungie gun and marowam is a
significantly taller order but with that
said there is one way that crollo could
conceivably
do it which would see him borrow the
non-ability of our final character who
could
technically beat meruem which is fink's
magub and straight away i need to say
this is by far the most unlikely of the
five characters i've mentioned to
actually succeed in dispatching the ant
king but thanks to fun technical nan
stuff it is still possible thanks as
hatsu the ripper cyclotron holds
theoretically infinite power
it's a very simple thing with every time
that things winds his arm clockwise his
aura increases and thus the power of his
eventual punch becomes stronger with 15
rotations being more than enough to
decimate a basic chimera ant not a whole
lot in the grand scheme of things and it
really does make you wonder what
hundreds perhaps even thousands of
rotations could generate
the biggest problem being how wildly
impractical it would be to achieve i
have no idea how long it would take and
meruem is
he's very unlikely to just you know
stand there and let it happen so in the
hypothetical scenario where it does work
thinks would need to charge the ripper
cyclotron beforehand
and there is also a very fair question
to examine being that does the ripper
cyclotron have a limit because some have
speculated that it cannot go beyond
finkx's maximum aura output which i find
to be
highly highly unlikely because if that
were the case and this would be one of
the worst enhancement abilities within
the entire series because characters
like gone or over gain can just flood
their full aura into their fists without
the tedious task of rotating their arms
like a gazillion times but it does make
sense with what we know of nen the
rotations of the cost the bonus aura is
the output it might come to a point
where the rotations start providing
diminishing returns on investment but
there will be returns nonetheless and
with how the ability is explained to us
there will come a point where the river
cyclotron is strong enough to one-shot
even marijuana i don't know where that
point is potentially hundreds of
thousands perhaps even a million
rotations maybe but it does
theoretically exist which once again is
more than we can say for the jins the
mahars the paristans and even the beyond
neteros of the world but if you'd like
to explore some more hunter to fund them
please do check out this video ranking
the 20 best nun abilities in the series
plenty of crazy stuff to examine so i
look forward to seeing you there